poverty here in the United States is so
much worse than most people realize
there is a recent story on alternet that
explained that as MIT as much as 10% of
the world's poor 10% of the poorest
people in the world live in the United
States there are areas according to a
recent investigation by the UN areas in
the state of Alabama where there are sub
third-world living condition for
residents in certain areas meaning these
people that live in the United States
are living in worse conditions than
people in non industrialized world a
country excuse me 10% of the world's
poorest people live here in the United
States and our government is telling us
that we have to give more money to rich
people that they deserve it just because
they've allegedly worked harder well how
does somebody who is born to billionaire
parents and then inherits billions or
hundreds of millions of dollars from
those parents how does that person earn
anything they didn't they received it
because they won the genetic lottery the
rest of us who've worked a job ever
since the day we turned fifteen years
old and could legally work depending on
the age regulations in your state
literally look that's how I spent my
15th birthday and I was excited about it
I woke up that morning I went to
McDonald's I filled out an application
had an interview that day and got hired
because that was the first day I could
work and I've held the job ever since
then I have worked my butt off and I
don't resent it I don't resent people
making more money than me but don't you
dare say that people who don't have as
much as the wealthy aren't hard workers
we're some of the hardest workers in
this country and yeah you want to give
us the crumbs from this tax cut you want
to tell us that we're too lazy then
we're not good enough or even worse
you want to do what Donald Trump jr.
just did and tell us we just need to
smile more in a recent interview with
CNBC from India Donald Trump jr. said
the following about poverty you go
through a town and I don't mean to be
glib about it but you can see the
poorest of the poor and there is still a
smile on a face you say hello it is a
different spirit than that which you see
in other parts of the world where people
walk around so solemn and I think there
is something unique about that now he
was talking about going through areas of
India and he's also trying to sell
condos that is 1 billion dollar property
there he's got a billion dollars worth
of condos to sell in India so he's
talking about going through the streets
of India where you just see these poor
people god they're so poor but they're
smiling and isn't that what they should
be doing right folks shouldn't they be
smiling at us shouldn't I walk down the
street as a billionaire and expect these
poor people to smile and say hello to me
I mean wouldn't anything else just be so
rude of them to do that is what Trump
jr. is telling us here and it's similar
to what dr. ben Carson secretary of HUD
said not that long ago that poverty is
just a state of mind now I know Ben
Carson's a little different because
unlike Trump he wasn't born with a
silver spoon in his mouth he did put in
the work he put in the effort and he
made something out of himself
unfortunately along the way somewhere he
lost his own mind and went a little
nutty but he says poverty is a state of
mind just think your way out of it I
guess and you got a smile to while
you're thinking your way out of it in
order for it to truly work because god
forbid the millionaires and billionaires
have to walk down the street and see
somebody not smiling because they don't
know where their next meal is going to
come from or because they're worried
about how they're gonna feed their kids
tomorrow or because their kid needs new
shoes and they can't afford it because
they had to pay their last $40 on an
insulin pill that's what's happening in
the United States and all at the same
time we're trying to give more and
more money to people who don't need any
more money we have people in this
country who could go the rest of their
lives without ever making one more
dollar and never even notice it and yet
we have other people in this country who
would give whatever they could to make
an extra dollar an hour so that they
could take care of themselves so that
they could take care of their families
so that they could buy them clothes when
they need it shoes when they need it
medicine when they need it and Donald
Trump jr. thinks we should just smile
more suffer through the you know smile
through the suffering I guess be happy
don't let him see you frown because then
they'll know you're poor and then god
forbid they may have to look at
themselves and say oh I have so much and
they have so little maybe I should give
them something god forbid they feel a
little bit of empathy for people in the
United States or 10% of the poorest of
the poor of the entire planet calls home
I want to thank David Pakman for letting
me sit in for him these last two days
David will be back tomorrow if you've
enjoyed listen to me you follow me on
twitter at fair and balanced you could
find me on youtube youtube.com slash the
Ring of Fire
thanks again both David and Pat for
letting me be here it's been a lot of
fun thanks for tuning in